die Zähne gefletzt das Schweißgerät
ununterbrochen im Einsatz in diesen
hallennahe Dallas Texas werden mit Angst
Millionen verdient
Ron Hubbert baut Bunker für Privatleute
und die sind gefragt wie nie
Einblicke in die Welt der
endzeitimmobilien
schauen Sie sich die Verarbeitung der
Wände oder der Decke an hoher Standard
wie bei einem neuen Haus
nichts erinnert hier an Industrie oder
Militär wir bauen luxusbunker für die
Elite der Welt
spätestens seit Corona und dem
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine weiß
er kaum noch wohin mit seinem Geld und
so bleibt mehr als genug übrig für seine
Lieblingsspielzeuge wie er sie nennt
Schusswaffen im Wert von mehreren
hunderttausend Dollar wenn das
Sicherheitsbedürfnis bei den Menschen
steigt klingelt bei Ron die Kasse und
selbst das sein Idol aus dem Oval Office
ausziehen musste sieht Ron mit einem
lachenden Auge
Donald Trump ist schlecht fürs Bunker
und Waffengeschäft als der Präsident war
ging die Verkaufszahlen für Schusswaffen
und Bunker nach unten denn die Leute die
Bunker kaufen das sind konservative und
die fühlten sich sicher also kauften sie
keine Bunker mit einem Demokraten im
Weißen Haus fühlen wir uns nicht mehr
sicher und kaufen Bunker Joe Biden ist
also großartig fürs Geschäft
großartig für sein Geschäft ist auch der
Krieg in Europa wo täglich Menschen
sterben wittert der Bunker Boss Profit
dieses Video zeigt ihn vor zwei Monaten
in der Ukraine er prahlt mit dem
Gedanken auch hier Fabriken eröffnen zu
wollen um seine Bunker auch an Ukrainer
zu verkaufen
Goldgräberstimmung im Kriegsgebiet
wenn dieser Krieg vorbei ist könnte das
doch ein Freizeitpark werden dann
könnten sich alle diese zerschossenen
Panzer ansehen
das wäre doch ein super thumbnail Foto
hier
die Angst vor Kriegen und Katastrophen
ist für mehr und mehr Amerikaner
mittlerweile so real dass sie bereit
sind hunderttausende auszugeben bei Ron
fahren Kunden mit Ferrari Maybach oder
wie in diesem Fall ihren Bentley vor das
ist hier alltäglich
Bild sind clair leitet ein großes
us-versicherungsunternehmen ich habe
dein Bunker fertig wie aufregend wenige
Wochen nach dem Kriegsbeginn in der
Ukraine bestellte er bei Ron einen
luxusbunker für 500.000 Dollar
viele Leute haben große Gefahren
abgeschrieben wie die Millennials oder
die Generation X sie haben die erfahren
wie es ist in Kriegszeiten zu leben denn
es gab ja seit den 60ern keinen mehr
der Krieg in der Ukraine führt Ihnen nun
vor Augen dass wir eben nicht in einer
sicheren Welt leben in der jeder
miteinander klarkommt
dieses Haus ist eine Festung das Anwesen
von Thomas janitschek der Arzt lebt seit
elf Jahren hier hat das Haus
größtenteils selbst gebaut und auch den
Bunker der darunter liegt nur der
Innenausbau fehlt noch
meine Frau hat darauf bestanden dass ich
erst das Haus und den Pool fertig baue
deshalb bin ich hier immer noch nicht
fertig
nächstes Jahr will Thomas den Ausbau
endlich abschließen wie viele seiner
Landsleute sinkt auch sein Vertrauen in
Institutionen im Ernstfall traut er der
Regierung nicht zu seine Frau und Kinder
zu beschützen
als Vater und Ehemann ist es mein Job
für die Sicherheit meiner Familie zu
sorgen
wenn ein Tornado kommt ist es
beispielsweise wichtig einen Bunker zu
haben
und da er weit genug unter der Erde
liegt kann er uns auch vor
Radioaktivität schützen
wer sich keinen maßgeschneiderten
Schutzraum leisten kann könnte im
Hinterland Zaubers fündig werden Dante
vicino hat hier 575 ehemalige
militärbunker gekauft im Zweiten
Weltkrieg dienten sie als Materiallager
heute vermietet er sie an Privatleute
kostenpunkt 45.000$ für 99 Jahre
wir bieten den Leuten eine Lösung für
Ihre Angst an diese Angst vor dem was
passieren könnte ist der Grund warum die
Menschen auf uns zukommen
und wenn Sie Ihren eigenen Bunker haben
machen sie sich auch nicht mehr so viel
Sorgen
dante hat fast alle seine Bunker
vermietet manche halten ihn nur für den
Ernstfall vor andere leben hier das
ganze Jahr mit ihrer Familie
vielleicht auch weil sie sich im Bunker
sicherer fühlen vor den zum Teil
abstrusen Gefahren vor denen dank des
Firma in diesem Video warnt Angst vor
realen Katastrophen gemischt mit
pseudo-religiösen endzeitphantasien wo
die Wirklichkeit Risse bekommt blüht die
Kundenakquise
die Bunker sind Zeugnis einer Zeit als
die Welt in den Abgrund blickte das neu
geweckte Interesse an ihnen zeigt dass
eine Epoche des Schreckens für viele
wieder vorstellbar ist und diese Furcht
Nutzen bunkerbauer in ganz Amerika aus
ich sehe darin kein ethisches Problem im
Gegenteil die Leute kommen ständig zu
mir und bedanken sich dass wir das hier
geschaffen haben
und Dante hilft Ihnen dabei es sich
möglichst behaglich zu machen so bietet
der studierte Architekt auch
verschiedene Dienste für den Innenausbau
an
wir haben die bunkerindustrie
demokratisiert in einem Ausmaß das es
vorher so nicht gab unsere Firma hat
diesen Markt also für verschiedenste
Leute zugänglich gemacht so dass es sich
auch die Mittelklasse leisten kann
rund jeder dritte US-Bürger denkt laut
Umfragen regelmäßig über das Ende der
Welt nach und so floriert ein Business
das vielen vor kurzem noch absurd
erschien um sich vor den Gefahren dieser
Welt verstecken zu können investieren
immer mehr Amerikaner viel Geld in ihren
Fluchtort aus Stahlbeton möglichst tief
unter der Erde